President Trump in South Korea this
morning following the conclusion of the
g20 summit in Japan
overnight he offered a surprising
invitation to North Korean dictator kim
jeong-hoon the president tweeted he's
willing to meet him at the demilitarized
zone today even if it's just for a brief
handshake the DMZ is the heavily
fortified border separating North and
South Korea if the meeting happens it
would be the third face-to-face meeting
between president Trump and cameras son
of the 20 countries involved in this
week's g20 summit in Japan were also
involved in the Korean War fighting in
Korea ended in 1953 but no peace treaty
was ever signed and North and South
Korea's you know remain separated today
because it was sandwiched between World
War two and Vietnam and because coverage
was often censored the Korean War has
been given little space in many history
books but over 7800 Americans remain
missing in action in Korea recently that
number was reduced by one that story is
the first in our new series who we are
it may be known as The Forgotten War but
what happened in a freshly divided Korea
between 1950 and 1953 left more than
600,000 dead and forklift monoids the
war that never officially ended just
came home again
cliff is now 90 living outside Boston
where he grew up seven decades ago he
met another Massachusetts boy George
Shivani in army training they became
fast friends it was a very likable guy
do anything for you in Korea the noid
and his fellow soldiers at first took
Pyongyang the capital of the north but
after China entered the war monoid and
his fellow soldiers were surrounded and
captured near the village of Ansan they
were forced to march in freezing
temperatures over a hundred and fifty
miles to puked on George Shivani
was badly wounded he had a leg amputated
in a makeshift mud hut hospital but died
not long after cliff was the man who
buried him in the winter of 1951
we dug a hole six inches deep and put
them in covered him with rocks do it
branches why was it so important for you
to do that uh just it was a friend a
friend in the services that's the best
friend you'll ever have and if you get
along good with them
you got your ass covered I mean doing
good he had you but Clifton oi was held
as a prisoner of war for another twenty
eight months before he was released he
returned to a hero's welcome got married
and along with his wife raised seven
children but cliff never forgot about
George left behind in a distant land
this January George japanies remains
were identified by the US government
when you learned that his remains had
been identified what went through your
mind but 68 years after he first buried
his friend cliff monoids did it again
this time in Somerville Massachusetts
the only key is that are buried here
Bob bean is a casualty officer for the
US military when we're able to
repatriate a soldier from a previous war
it's more of a celebration it gives a
community an opportunity to come out and
not only appreciate and show their love
and respect for the soldier we're
burying but they're also showing the 11
respect for all who have served and
sacrificed George japanís final resting
place is less than two miles for more
cliff still lives
[Music]
everything is it being a prisoner of war
for 33 months in total Clifton went back
into the Army Wow for another decade it
was a letter carrier raised 7 kids along
with his wife married for more than 60
years his wife actually just died in
April so cliff has been dealing with so
much one of the most extraordinary
people I've ever met Wow that was so
powerful just the idea of wanting to
have him home that idea of no man left
behind and and you see those black pio
wmia flags flying for a reason because
people want you to remember you know
they call the World War two generation
the greatest generation we should have a
name for this one don't forget about the
Korean War veterans absolutely